Welcome to the Chiro Show where open source
make systems
the key. Daverwolf's
engineers
gather around the best infrastructure
tool we found.
KAIROS,
making it simple and clean.
Star us.
There's so much more.
From edge computing to the cloud of heights,
there is an architect.
See why
open source contributors
join the fight.
The future of infrastructure
starts tonight.
So grab your coffee,
settle
Hello, and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
I'm your host, David Flanagan, also known across
the Internet as Rawkode.
And this is an episode of Rawkode Live,
a show where we take a look at
amazing and interesting and fun
all of the above cloud native projects to
help make your cloud native lives all that
little bit easier. And today, we're taking a
look at a pretty cool project called Kairos.
To guide us today, we are joined by
two fantabulous guests from Spectral Cloud and contributors
and maintainers of the Kairos project.
Hello.
Welcome to the show. This is Mauro and
Ettore. How are you both?
Hello, everyone.
Hey, everyone. Thank you.
All right. Let's
take a wee minute just to say hello
and introduce yourselves. We'll start at the top
right there with you, Mauro, and then move
down. Please take it away.
Yeah.
So hi, everyone. I'm Mauro. I'm originally from
Guatemala,
but I've been living in Europe, for a
while now, currently in Belgium.
And,
yeah, I'm working
at SpectraCloud as a staff engineer at the
moment
with Tore.
He's my boss, so I hope this goes
well.
I'm trying to
put out the word for KAROS in different
events. So KCDs,
KubeCon,
me expect to see me there.
And I'm part of maintainer part, I guess,
DevRel or something like that within the team.
Yeah. And on my free time,
if I have any because of the newborn,
I I try to go out running
or playing the guitar a little bit. That's
it.
Awesome. Thank you so much.
Yeah. I'm Ettore Giacinto.
I'm from Italy. I'm head of open source
at SpectroCloud.
I basically created
Kairos at the beginning.
And, yeah, since then, it grew as a
very
much
bigger open source project.
I really like
working in the open,
and I've been also very
passionate open source contributor.
So, for instance, I was an ex Gentle
developer also.
So I like to put my hands in
the lower stack of the system. I like
to understand every single piece.
I've been also
playing with AI.
So maybe some of you know maybe local
AI or I've been contributing to Lama c
plus plus
And, yeah, that's
that's a little bit about me.
Awesome. Very nice. Italy.
Italy and then and then have it run
there.
Nice. Awesome. Italy
and
currently Belgium.
I mean, if if you're in Belgium, I
hope you like beer. Right? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Definitely. I mean,
it's part of the reasons, not the only
one.
Yeah. I mean, Italy has some good beer
too, but I think in Europe, Belgium is
probably one of the places to go. The
the challenge with Belgian beer is you have
two and then you're ready for your bed.
At least I don't know. That is true.
Yeah. Yeah. Like, it's funny when people don't
know that fact and think they can just
drink their beers like they do somewhere else.
No. Low alcohol beer in Belgium is, 6%.
Right? So
Yeah.
Anyway,
so today we're taking a look at Kairos.
Which one of you would like to kick
things off and just tell us a little
bit of a high level what is the
Kairos project?
Maybe you do it, Tore, because, I mean,
you have the whole thing behind Yeah.
So,
basically, Kairos is a metalinux distribution.
So
it's a way to streamline
the management
of an OS.
The peculiarity
is that it's vendor neutral. So it doesn't
really have any,
I would say, dependency on a specific OS,
which basically means you can use it as
a layer of your infrastructure.
So if you are trying to build an
immutable infrastructure,
you can combine it with other pieces. So
for instance, if you
you're used to use Ubuntu, you can use
Ubuntu
plus KIROS.
And what you'll keep, it's an immutable system
at the end.
Immutable system, it's very
much
different from a standard Linux system because you
cannot really write on all the the folders
that you are typically used to. So you
cannot just install a new software with, so
to say, apt get.
We're going to
upgrade
the system every time. So this is how
it works with
providing
updates or changes to our running system. So
you do that with this AB mechanism,
similar to Android phones, right? So where you
have a new updates coming in and you
say, yes, I want to install the new
updates. So the
phone goes off, it applies the upgrade, and
you start with the new system. So this
is how
Kairos basically transform
any
other base operative system too,
if that makes sense. So if you have
OpenSUSE,
you have Alpine, it doesn't really matter. You're
going to upgrade those systems in the same
consistent way.
And
on top of that, you can manage that
very easily with Kubernetes.
So you will find in the Kairos documentation
a lot of
references to run it with Kubernetes, because when
it comes to managing
fleets of machines,
then it comes very handy to use also
Kubernetes as a management platform
for upgrades.
Okay.
So I I've got a few questions. You
know, I think immutable Linux distributions for the
average cloud native developer, we're all familiar with
maybe one or two, maybe not having shipped
them to prod, but know, I think the
original one in this space was core OS
from way back in the day Cool. Which
was built on top of RPM
West Street.
And then modern times, we've got flat car,
which I think is very similar.
But the reason
they're they're built on RPM OS tree, which
means they're probably stuck to Fedora and, you
know, Red Hat Lake distributions.
But you've mentioned Ubuntu already and almost that
this is gastro agnostic.
So I'm going to assume that Kairos isn't
using RPM OS three under the hood, and
maybe you're doing a different pattern for AB
upgrades. Can you maybe go into that in
a bit more detail?
Yeah. Correct. So we do have
specific engine built for upgrades. So it's
based on container images.
So
every time you are doing an upgrade, you're
actually
pulling an OCI image, which contains the upgrades.
So,
maybe it's done like in a one to
one
mapping. So, the same image that you can
run with Portman or Docker or whatever you
prefer, it's the same image that it's going
to be applied in AB style on the
host.
And by the way, yes, it follows also
some of the concept of core OS and
for instance, also K3 OS, which was kind
of very
inflated,
I would say, because we have Cloud config
support as well. So there is like this
kind of
configuration mechanism
extended
that allows to configure the system.
And yeah, basically
it goes to the point that,
like you said, it's
distribution agnostic. So it doesn't really depends on
Red Hat,
RPMs or
DEPS.
For instance, we have Alpine flavors.
Yeah. Maybe if I can add a little
bit there.
One interesting fact, in my opinion, that we
have there is that the new image that
you're building is always built outside of the
running system. Some of these mechanisms like OS
root
or
AB Root, sorry, or OS three are
when you're applying those changes, you're applying it
on the passive image that you have so
that when you restart, then you that's the
image that you're gonna get next.
But that means that you would not have
an image to go back in case something
goes wrong with the current image that you
have. In our case, what we,
our approach is to say you always have
this passive image that you can,
in case something goes wrong in in an
upgrade, you you you go back into that
one. And worst case scenario, you can always
have
the
recovery image
so that you can do the
Ninja
OS management stuff. Right?
Okay.
Nice.
So one of the things that caught my
eye on on the website is and I
haven't seen this a lot before, but when
you talk about immutable images and OCI, right,
these things can tend to get a little
bit
crazy size wise. People
are not great at optimizing container
files generally.
But Kairos claims to also be an edge
operating system, and I wonder how you balance
that,
you know, giving people the ability to ship
essentially container images as operating systems, but also
keep them lightweight and ship them to the
edge. Like,
is Kairos different from the other tools that
I've tried this in the past?
Well, that's a good question. I would say
there are few things that we do.
First, maybe the most interesting one is you
don't need to always ship everything in a
single image.
While we do,
I would say, that from one source up,
You can also split down the system with
system the ACS extensions.
So there are extension mechanisms that allows you
to pack part of the image separately out
of the container image building process.
However,
when we treat
container images,
we don't consider all the layers, so to
say, we just flatten the image that it's
being used, if that makes sense. So in
terms of,
if you are
maybe not well used to optimize size of
images, you don't really have to take care
of that unless
you are adding a lot of panels that
you mean to have in the image. So
for instance, for a specific use case that
you have, I don't for instance, I'm thinking
about
NVIDIA Jetson
SDK or these kind of things that might
be big. So those can be either in
the image or either as an extension that
you can
basically sideload install separately,
like if I have to talk into
Android
words.
So
something that you install separately
and you manage separately out of the OS
lifecycle.
One thing that I've been thinking lately is
that the way I see Keras is like
it's kind of an OS
that
when you don't need to go into the
details, it steps out of your way. You
know? Like, we we try to come with
good
standards. Like, in this case, for example, you
will base it from the way minimal
Ubuntu image, and that's what you would be
building on. But
in the case where you really need to
go to the details,
for example, you'd you really need a small
image, you can go and remove firmware yourself
that that you're not going to need. So
it's as flexible in that way, we could
say.
Okay. Two more questions, and then we will
get hands on the keyboard and then start
getting people through the documentation.
Now right on the homepage of Keras, it
says you take your Linux system and a
Kubernetes distribution.
Is KAIROS
for building bespoke Kubernetes
images, or is it could it just be
generic Linux images? Like, who is this applicable
to? Who should be paying attention to the
project?
That's a great question. So it really doesn't
have,
I would say, a specific preference. It
really is suited to use it with Kubernetes
because of the management layer we discussed about.
You can really
use it for
any project that can be even kiosks
or appliance mode
or running virtual machines.
And these are all use cases that we
see in the community as well. So it's
not really
about Kubernetes by per se, but it's whatever
you want to
simplify the management of Linux
OS.
And it comes also with,
I would say,
nice features to have, like trusted boot or
high security
mechanism,
like
Ben is
quoting in the chat. Thanks, Ben.
And, yeah, exactly. So there
are many, many feature set that you gain
by just using Kairos on top of a
standard distro.
Nice.
Yeah. So Ben, as in the comments saying,
you know, it's it's nice to hear you
talk about system based system extensions because a
lot of people kind of just don't mention
them and forget they exist or don't want
them to exist. Yes. But I think they're
a very powerful thing. And in fact, you
know, Leonard Potter rings article that he wrote
many years now, but fitting all of this
together to build, like, the ideal Linux distribution.
I feel we're getting so close in the
modern day. So
yeah. Ben is also in using Keras without
Kubernetes
at scale. So that is awesome. Always nice
to hear from people that are using the
project.
Now the last question before we go hands
on is a leading question. But, you know,
when we talk about who should be paying
attention to this, right, we've got different classes
of cloud native developers.
There are the people that go on to
the EC two console. They spin up an
Ubuntu box. They run a few commands in
a shell, and that's their production.
Then there's the opposite end where the people
our infrastructure is code, building bespoke images, looking
for immutability, etcetera. Right? Is Kairos a project
that can be adopted full spectrum of cloud
native developers? Anyone from single
VM on EC two to at scale production.
And bear in mind, we're about to go
hands on, so we're hoping that we we
get a correct answer here. Right? But it's
applicable to everyone. Is it easy enough for
people to pick up and ship to prod?
I would say so because we have also
called images published. Right? So we have the
full spectrum covered in that case.
Of
course,
we are going to have
I'm not going to lie. I mean,
the cloud aspect, there are some optimization that
we want to take specifically into integrating with
copy, because currently we have management
mechanism that allows to
manage the fleet in a much more granular
way, I would say, because CAPI doesn't quite
fit to this
paradigm. So we're going to
work on this integration more closer.
But yeah. I mean, it really have the
all the best and whistles to to be
from development to to production.
And it's been used also, yeah, of course,
at the edge.
Yeah. I would I would add just that.
Is
if you are comfortable at the OS level,
then, hopefully,
yes.
Would be mainly people who are really just
at the platform level and up who
rather have something where they can just click
that might feel it's a bit of a
stretch, I would say. But,
yeah, we we try to simply file as
you were the saying
from Leonard Potter. In all of these concepts
that are there, we don't throw them in
your face. Right? Like, you don't need to
learn all those things in order to use
Kairos. Right? We did the
hard work, the homework to go investigate how
those things work and make the Keras agent
do them for you.
Perfect.
Well, I think it's about time we share
my screen and see how far we can
get with the Keras project.
Alright. Let's get my screen up here.
Perfect.
So for anyone who wants to learn more,
you can go to kairos.io.
This is a CNCF sandbox project.
Maybe we'll talk about the that process later
on. And there is a quick start guide,
which on Rawkode Live is my favorite button
because that's where we wanna show how to
get started with the project.
And there there are quite a lot of
no. Maybe not a lot. There are some
prerequisites
to get started for KAIROS. And this is
one of the challenging things for a project
like this is that you do need virtual
machines and other things. Right? It's not just
Docker run and off you go. So
for anyone who does want to follow along,
just make sure you follow the documentation.
I'm gonna use the virtual machine manager that's
not listed here, but hopefully that's alright.
And I I actually sat and watched this
video earlier. I've got to say this is
a good demo. Like this showed me like
any question I had was answered by this
video. You know Cool. Feel free to go
check that out for anyone watching as well.
And I'll make sure that the links to
all of this are in the description for
later.
Now because I don't trust my Internet, I
have downloaded this ISO here
in advance. That's the only thing I've really
done.
And we're gonna create a virtual machine and
get started.
Now before I pull up the the kind
of VM manager and stuff like that, like,
what is what is the take home for
people when they work for this get started
guide? Right? What is the what will they
achieve
by following this guide, what will they understand?
Who wants to tackle that?
Basically,
you will get a system
running with, Kubernetes,
but this one will be immutable. You don't
have to worry about how it was made
immutable. You don't have to worry about spinning
up and configuring Kubernetes.
It's all running there for you.
Nice. So I'm gonna get a Kubernetes cluster
from this virtual machine.
I like Kubernetes.
So I just select this.
And
there were
memory limits. Am I gonna be okay with
the two twenty, I think? Or should I
I would put 40 for storage just in
case.
Yeah. I think it did say 35, didn't
it, in the documentation?
I know I I know I don't need
to throw 32 gig of RAM at this,
but I will. I've got I have a
20 gig of RAM in this machine. I
I never use it. So today's the day.
Go. Alright.
Then
in in the getting started, we go through
the interactive install. So if you can select
that one, that would be the best. Yeah.
I was wondering if I can make this
bigger.
Let's see.
Yeah. That's fine.
Where is can I change fonts or anything?
I don't use Numboxes often.
Maybe in the three dots, it allows you
to
Yeah.
Not really. Oh, or configuration.
No. That's Oh, that's for LibVert. It's not
for these. Yeah.
I don't wanna go mess them with that.
Maybe.
No.
Unfortunately,
I think we started in not the interactive
mode.
So just just to mention, there are different
ways to configure
Kairos system. This is the default one, which
would spin up. And let's say that you're
in an edge location,
you can, take a screenshot of that QR
code and give it to,
the terminal in another system, and then you
would configure it, you know, to to simplify
things because this system might not have a
keyword or something like that.
Alright. So should I start this again then?
Yeah. Okay. Got it.
Can't believe I broke it already. I'm only
two minutes in.
I guess I could just shut it down
and start it again. Yeah.
Alright. So The interactive one, the third. There
we go. Yep.
And this one, we really made it thinking
on someone who is coming for the first
time to the system. This is probably not
what the
power user of Kairos will ever
use. This is the ones we use every
time we're testing the system just for a
quick setup.
It will make a couple of questions like
like it's doing right now,
asking
in which device you want to install. By
default, it will find the
device with the biggest space in your system.
So you can just hit enter
if you wanna install there, or you can
select the one you prefer.
Do I want to create any users?
Right. And in this case, for example, we
can say, yes. We want to create a
user, but many times for systems
in
at the edge or now that we're talking
about this special purpose of bringing systems on
the cloud, many times we say we don't
even want SSH in. Right? Like, we
want those systems to be as secure as
possible, and one one way of making the
that is by not including any users. But
if you're just starting and want to play
with it, having a user is a good
way to test it.
Alright.
And we'll call our user Kairos.
Password we normally put Kairos. Yep. I'll do
that.
Then here, if you have your keys on
GitHub, you can put your
GitHub user and it will fetch them for
you. Otherwise, you can just hit enter and
it will not put anything there.
Yeah. Maybe SSH should now be good because
I can change my own font size then.
Indeed.
Alright. Maybe user and admin, I'm gonna say
yes. Yeah. And do we want full mesh
support?
In this case, I would say no. But
generally, when we spin up multiple machines,
you have the ability to have a mesh
network between them so that they can decide
who is the control plane and which ones
are the workers.
Okay.
And do we want k three s? If
I say no, do I get another option
or should I say yes? Here, I would
say yes.
It's also possible to do k c r
s, but
for for the sake of testing,
we've run many more times K three s
since it was the one we had since
the beginning of the project. I would go
with that one for now.
Alright. I've also said my settings are okay,
and now we have a machine,
I guess, booting. That's correct. So if you
saw there was a blue part there, that
is the cloud config that the
installation,
created for us. And and that's the main
way in which we're going to configure Kairos
system. It's just a traditional cloud in it
like,
syntax.
And then right now, it's, just going to
do everything Kairos related
to make sure that you have the proper
partitions on your system.
Yeah.
And I feel I should just have used
KVM, and this would have been a bit
more interesting,
at least a bit more readable for you
all.
We have a box now. Right? Is that
it?
On Node That's that's correct. So now you
could just reboot and then
we it would it should spin on
an install Kairos system.
Okay.
Oh, I can't spell or take.
Alright.
Also, sometimes when you're testing this, make sure
to remove the CD,
because otherwise, it's gonna just go again
and do that. It happens all the time
because not all the systems have that automatically.
Go away. Here we go.
Don't know why they can't change the oh,
wait.
Preferences. Just let me do it. No. It's
the same sentence.
Alright.
Now we have Kairos recovery,
remote recovery, state reset. So let's put this
up.
Correct.
And yeah. So those main
options that you see there is basically the
interaction that you get with Kairos. You get
your active system, which is the one that
you're normally gonna be putting on. The passive
one,
which is in case something went wrong with
an upgrade, for example, or you're gonna go
to your previous system
and then the recovery in case something goes
really, really wrong.
Alright. So, I mean, the docs cover everything
we've just done. All the questions are here
and the answers,
even the reminder to eject the CD. And
now we've done the first boot. So in
theory, we should be able to SSH now
into our machine once we have an IP
address.
Correct.
Alright.
Whenever the IP would be available in the
logs. It doesn't look like it.
See if I can get the IP.
Should have used KVM.
So I can
hey. I I picked the password. Right? So
let's just kairos. Yeah. Kairos.
Put in there.
So I can see we've got our CNI
interface. We've got Flannel, and we've got our
local IP address here. So 100215.
I'll get it on your tab. So SSH
KAOS 100215.
I'm assuming I can work to that from
my local machine, right?
It
depends on the network, I guess, that the
virtual machine manager
sets.
Yeah. I don't think we got a route.
Yeah. You will probably need a 1 90
in order to access it.
Let's see what I've got.
Maybe grep pro 192.
I'm not seeing one.
Yeah.
So maybe not.
Good question.
I don't even have oh, come on.
Alright.
I broke it.
I should have looked into numboxes before doing
this.
I mean, I could always add a root,
right? But it depends on what the link
is. And I don't wanna spend too much
time
debugging and trying to work this out. But
let me quickly
IP.
Oh, we did link.
So I was expecting some sort of bridge
or something, but it hasn't done any of
that. Right?
Sorry. What was that? I was expecting it
to create some sort of device,
bridge device here or tunnel or whatever. Right?
And to the virtual machine, but it hasn't
done any of that.
So
No. The default of I think if it's
boxes, it's using at the end KVM or
KN with using user
mode network, which is completely
isolated from the host then.
Alright. There goes that plan. Bleach.
Shall we pop over to your machine where
we can see a working demo rather than
my Sure. One?
Feel free.
Let me know when you see my screen.
Yeah, I'll just swap that right now.
All right, we got it. All right. So
I am just creating,
I am using Copilot here and
it will just
same thing spinning up PM,
create and run.
And we should be able to see it
here. Again, also interactive install.
Sorry. What software is this?
This is called Copilot,
if I remember correctly.
Poor guys because now Copilot, I guess, is
a bad name to have, but they chose
it before.
And
it allows me to manage my workstation
because I'm normally working from
Apple computer.
Okay. So
let me move this thing at the bottom
that doesn't let me see.
Oops. Sorry.
There.
Okay.
Create users. Yes. Kairos. Kairos.
Again,
GitHub.
That
should add my keys. Admin,
yes.
No mesh support at the moment. Yes. K
three s. Settings. Okay. Yes. Like I was
saying, it created at the top
cloud
in it like configuration,
and now it's going through
all the different
stuff that it needs to do. Let me
also get back to
where we are here.
Then we're gonna need to reboot,
and then we SSH into the system.
And I can see
here,
Already, I'm getting an IP.
So I'm gonna go into
my terminal.
Okay.
So let's see how this is going. Yep.
Reboot.
Let's wait a bit. Kaira's already there.
Yeah. So while you were spinning this up,
I did check the documentation on Numboxes. And
all you need to do is install LibVert
daemon config network and start the system d
service. But we'll we'll continue on your machine.
So Okay. It wasn't it wasn't easy fix.
And
it's coming up now.
Alright. So now I can s s h
in. As you see, I didn't have to
add the password
because it already
fetched my
credentials
my my key from GitHub.
And now here, I can
basically
ask Root to something like k nine s,
where
I can
show, for example,
the
cluster that is spinning up at the moment.
And that's basically it. Now you can play
with your cluster.
So the default image is shipping KNI nest
as well?
Yeah. It's something that we're constantly discussing, like
what should be in the base image.
For some people, it should be about stripping
it completely.
We think that at least to get a
bit of an idea, play with it, it's
nice to have it. But, yeah, we we
haven't decided whether we should remove it or
not. So is kubectl there or do I
need to use k three s kubectl?
Like
Kube
CTL is here, so you can,
I guess, do this? Yeah.
Cool. Alright. Yep.
Michael in the chat is asking, is this
similar to Talos? So maybe we could talk
about how are how are these different.
That's a very good question.
I don't know if you wanna dive deep
deep into that one, Tore.
Yeah, I mean,
there is some,
I would say,
crossing of the paths into the two projects
because they are both trying to deliver on
OS which is
focused on
workloads.
However,
Keras is, first, not restricted to Kubernetes
and it's not
a Linux OS by per se. It's a
meta Linux distribution that you can put on
top of any distro.
Talos
is a complete Linux distro while
Keras is not. So they're
kind of
similar in the sense that both let you
a system with Kubernetes in that sense,
but they do it in a very different
way.
And,
yeah, it it really depends, I guess, on
the use case here.
Yeah. I mean, I can add some more
context there. I'm quite familiar with with Talos
as well. I mean,
you know, Kairos and Talos, from my perspective,
both give me an immutable distribution.
But Talos is very opinionated in the way
they do it and that they take over
PED one. Right? So they only expose
a gRPC API for communicating with the server
over Talos control.
You cannot SSH in. That's not an option.
And, you know, there's no system d or
anything like that. So the learning curve can
quite be quite steep because you have to
relearn how to do the the basics.
Whereas what I'm seeing so far from Kairos
is
I get to bring my own,
you know, Linux distribution, but I get the
perks and the benefits of having something that
is immutable.
You know? And then
there's other things I I think we're gonna
get to. I'm not sure, but, you know,
there's to build their own
version of Talos can be quite challenging. And
I'm curious to see how that works with
Kairos. Like, how do I actually bring my
own distribution and how do I configure things
to my own liking and stuff like that?
So maybe we'll get to that in just
a moment.
Yeah. Maybe it's important to mention
what something we've noticed is that many projects
or companies
don't have the luxury of being in a
completely greenfield
project, so to speak, or or something modern
that is already cloud native
ready.
So they actually require
either multiple workloads,
and some of them might be legacy and
only run on Linux, but not on Kubernetes.
Moving to Kubernetes might be,
too costly for them or simply not an
option.
Or we also see cases where
some companies are already spending money on licenses
with a certain provider.
So in all of these scenarios, Kairos can
adapt to you.
Well, as you say in the other option
with Talos, it's more opinionated in that sense.
The the result of what you can do
is probably the same to some degree with
both distros, at least when it's on the
Kubernetes side.
But
we do it in a flexible way where,
for example, if you need to
I don't know. Even if for you, it's
important, the know how of your engineers,
and you cannot just let go of all
that you've built on Ubuntu,
then you can continue working on Ubuntu. Yeah.
Yeah.
Clear example could be, for instance, we do
provide support for Nvidia
JX Orin,
your OS. But then you get all the
benefits of using an immutable OS,
AB system upgrades,
and yada yada. So you get that extra
layer also on
a situation where you typically wouldn't do, even
with Raspberry Pi. You could deploy Keras on
Raspberry,
and you can get all the OSs you
want and switch between OSs
by providing a different container image.
So this is the kind of
vision that Keras accomplishes.
And it doesn't matter what OS it is.
So
you could literally take whatever
OS is out there or even build your
own OS. You could build your Linux from
scratch and put Keras on top so you
don't have to handle the upgrades
for your OS. Right?
Alright. Let's get into some of those details
there because those are pretty bold claims.
Firstly,
Michael said Talos wasn't an option because of
CNI limitations.
So I'm gonna assume the conversation here is
that with
sorry. The buzzer with Kairos, you can use
any CNI implementation.
Yes. Yeah. Correct. You can use any Kubernetes
distribution.
So we currently
support
KZeros and K3s, but we have also
community providers like Kube admin. So Kube admin
is supported as well.
And you can build whatever
provider for your specific Kubernetes distribution and have
the configuration bits you really need
from the whole OS stack. So if you
need some dependency in the system, you can
just bring this in.
Yep.
Now when you say you can bring
any Linux distribution even to the point of
saying Linux from scratch, which is oh, I'll
pop back over to here just now.
Even, like, building your own learnings from scratch.
Right? I'm I'm curious to understand how this
works. So say,
I want to bring our Linux into the
mix, and I wanna get that one running
with with iOS. What is it you're doing
to that Linux distribution to give us
less automation and configurability and immutability?
That's a good question. So
Keras basically tries to identify which
system
you need to use
on
the image. And based on that, it's going
to install the required services.
On top of that, it's going to start
the Keras agent binaries
and some configuration that might be required
for the OS
to function properly,
like configuration,
system settings,
like users and these kinds of things.
So it doesn't
It tries to play with the tools that
are already there.
So I can bring you an example. So
Linux from scratch is a good example because
I've been exactly targeting that in my mind
from the beginning.
So as I was saying, I'm an next
game to developer. So I was always doing
my Linux from scratch. Right? And this system
should have been working also on that. It's
very much important. So Alpine works as well
because we don't do any
magic.
Basically, we just
do a very clean layout. It depends on
boot loaders. So for instance, we do support
GRUB and System Deboot,
and we leverage heavily on those to do
the operation that we need to do.
So to say a little bit of the
logic, it's moved to the bootloader rather than
OS to make it more agnostic when we
do lifecycle management like upgrades.
And it's obviously not magic. Right? Like, there
are limitations to where we can run. Right
now, it's only Systemd and OpenRC
as init systems.
But at least the code is written in
a way that it's you can expand it.
Right? Like, if you really need to run
on a different init system, then it's just
a matter of telling the Kairos agent how
that init system works.
But the same thing for package management. Right?
Like, if you bring your own distribution that
you created and you also create
a different package manager, of course, we're not
gonna know how to install those packages. But
the the mechanism to just extend that is
right there,
and it makes it easy to to have
all the features of Kairos in your own
OS.
Okay. So with that in mind then, if
I said, let's share my screen and build
a custom Kairos image that we can boot.
Is that something we can do in the
next thirty minutes?
Mhmm. I mean, yeah.
Part part if we continue in the getting
started,
that's a bit of where we want to
what we want to do.
Let me see if I have it here.
So the the second section of the getting
started, the building and upgrading
will tell you how to
create a new Kairos image based on an
existing Kairos image. And then at the bottom,
it says
build from scratch guide.
And that that's the
documentation we would need to follow if we
wanted to do that.
Alright.
Let let me share my screen again. So
Yep.
Let's go
back over here. And your screen is still
on. Let me swap that over.
Alright. So I did follow your instructions there.
We don't need to start with bells from
scratch. I mean, there are examples in the
repo and I think we'll definitely take a
look at them.
But let's go with the
Getting started. Yeah.
Yeah. Like, just, you know, just taking a
base image and then enriching it for some
ways. So the things that pop into my
head right off the bat are, okay, what
what are the bases that I can start
with? What are you building these images for
to get people started quickly?
Yeah. For exam the the example that I
have there is, let's say that for some
reason, you need Ruby in the system that
Keras doesn't provide.
And in order to do that, all you
would need to do is
use us from one of our Keras images,
then in the next step of the Dockerfile,
you would say, okay. App get update, app
get install
Ruby,
and then do a normal Docker build for
that image,
and you're pretty much done. Now you can
give this image that you've created to the
previous
machine that we just installed, and it will
upgrade to that system that now has Ruby
in it.
Nice.
So I see as a base choice of
operating system, people can come to this page
and then go for OpenSUSE,
Rocky Linux, Fedora, Alpine, Debian, etcetera.
I'm gonna keep things simple just because I
did do
a pull because it was a chunky sized
image. This Ubuntu base
is two and a half gig. So why
don't we
just tweak this a little bit?
And then okay. I can't I mean, I
could pod man it. I'll just do docker
to keep it simple. I don't wanna make
things
hard on myself again.
And
I'll grab this.
What happened there?
So
we did from.
Yep. Kui ubuntu
tag. One thing to notice here is if
you pick pick images
with the core,
you don't get basically the the Kubernetes distribution
and Kubectl
and K9s and etcetera, etcetera. Yeah. So there
are
Sorry, Nicole. No. No. Just
just to clarify, basically, with images that they're
using now, we're going to lose K9s or
K3s,
K3s if we do upgrades.
I I get that. I'm I'm I'm okay
with that. I just wanna kinda show people
how they can go from a Dockerfile to
an ISO to building the thing, right, for
some means. So, I mean, I'm a I'm
hoping
and assuming that anyone watching this is already
quite comfortable putting together Dockerfile. Right? I mean,
we can just do the classic example
of now we have NGINX running inside of
a container. So
with that, what I could do then,
it's just a docker image build dash t.
Let's call this Rawkode
engine x. You're you're gonna need to publish
it so that the system can consume it.
If the system has Internet, I don't I
haven't checked it. If can can you validate
if the VM has Internet?
Well,
I mean okay. So you were suggesting that
we built up the VM that I already
got run got working
and tell it to rebase off of another
image. I was gonna say, like,
the step that is missing from my mind
is if I do this
Mhmm. Tell me about Buildx. That's okay. I
get a container image. But if I want
to create that as an ISO, is that
the default flow or are you saying you
would boot Kairos core and then tell it
to consume a Docker image as an additional
layer?
Maybe I just not understanding that. Well, both
work, actually.
It it's a totally valid flow,
the one you're describing.
Okay. So is it easy now for me
on my standard Linux machine to say, okay,
let's convert Rawkode NGINX to an ISO that
I can just DD onto some cloud
virtual machine?
Is that
a common workflow or would you say
publishing the container image and using that as
a layer on another
Kairos as the preferred approach? Like, what should
people
aspire to if they wanna ship this stuff
to production?
So
we have dedicated tooling for that. So from
the container image, basically,
you can build all the artifacts you need.
So for upgrades,
you are okay with the container image only.
So up to this point, you just publish
the container image to a registry,
and then you would point the node to
that image.
If you would instead of, you know, create
an ISO,
there is the Aurora boot two that you
can point the image like this one, and
it will create an ISO out from this.
Alright. What Came
with the WebUI.
You can open the WebUI to
drive this in front.
What did you say? It was called Aurora.
Yep.
Aurora BIM? That's right? Yep. That's correct.
Alright. All the way to the bottom,
there is a WebUI.
Or, otherwise,
if you wanna use the CLI,
there's there are examples offline ISO build from
container images.
Alright. I mean, I'm happy to use a
web UI, but now that I'm seeing unified
kernel images in secure bit, I mean, my
interest is more than peaked. Like, we're getting
into the fun stuff now.
Alright.
Where was that web UI?
Oh, I don't see.
Ben says OCI is a %
easier with Kairos upgrade. I guess I guess
we're used to that flow as well.
But, yeah, in this case, it's it's a
total valid approach that you want to create
your ISOs because I don't know. You need
to send them through
USBs
for people to go and up upload because
they don't have Internet in those boxes. Right?
So it's a completely valid
flow.
Okay. So I've
so I clicked on this create a custom
cloud image. We you know, we've kind of
done this step already.
So
we added
NGINX.
Now I can use docker run
to then create the ISO. So this is
using
oh, we got a different registry now. Right?
So the Aurora boot isn't on Quay. It's
on Scarf SH. I don't know where that
is.
Oh, yeah. That you can if you don't
want to see that, you can just at
the top of the page next to the
sun,
you can see you can select not to
have that on the left.
This one, yeah. Personal use and then you
will see the Query.
Yeah.
All right. Okay.
Nice. So this just takes my current working
directory, it makes it a build.
Oh, no. It's create it's taking a build
directory,
bending it to Aurora, but
sets
these things.
Alright.
I don't know what that's doing. I'm just
gonna run it. I'm feeling brave today. You
just need to put the name of your
image in
where it says my custom image and we
will need to have because this one wants
Cloud config, we would need to create a
Cloud config as well.
Alright. So I don't have a build directory.
Is that okay? Yeah. That's okay because it's
adding it on top of your current
directory.
Alright.
I run a weird shell, so I will
need to have this come through bash.
My image
now is it gonna have
access to my local Docker image context?
Or will I actually need to push this
so well? Okay. In the second line, we
added the Docker socket, so you should have
access to them. Yeah. Okay. Can I just
remove the Cloud config and say we don't
care about that?
Yeah.
I don't know if we're going to be
able to log in, but
All right. Okay. So But you can. Technically,
you can.
Sorry,
I've went completely off script and now we're
just going No, that's fantastic.
There's Cloud Config.
Yeah. You can take an example of Cloud
Config probably from the getting I think in
the getting started I put it It's up,
no? There is no example up in the
docs, no? There was. There there
definitely was something.
I remember looking at it and seeing the
Yeah.
In the getting started, if you're pressing configuration,
go down and you will see one.
Perfect.
So let's just call this cloud config.
Put my
username in so I get my keys.
I'm
okay with all of that. Alright.
That's Now, the path and the build here
is this
because this is this
is a parameter
to the container image. So is this within
the context?
Yeah.
You're going to have to add it. So
I need to add another volume
at the Yeah.
All right. We can do that.
So I can just do PWD
and
call that cloud
like so.
And I call it cloudconfig.com.
Yeah.
Okay.
Let's see.
Cool. Cool. Hopefully Aurora isn't too big. No,
no. I think this one is a lot
smaller.
All right. So Michael was also in the
comments saying, Okay, what have I involved off
of a hypervisor?
I don't want container inception.
Oh, I mean, I think that's the path
we're on now actually. Right? So I mean,
you could do this
in a hypervisor?
Maybe I don't understand the question, Michael. Feel
free to
expand on that a little bit.
What if I'm building off of a hypervisor?
Like,
Michael, do you mean, like, you already are
in a VM?
Do you want to start building VMs within
it? Or or what does it mean?
Yeah. Possibly. But that seems like completely container
what if you wanna build off of an
ISO? Okay. So what if they're from statement
as another ISO rather than a container image?
No.
I think that would be a problem. Right,
Tore? Our
concept is starting always from Yeah. Container. Yeah.
Is a container image in
KARO's world. You have
basically, you start always from a container, right?
From the container image, you get all the
final artifacts,
including raw disks image for cloud
providers,
like even OpenStack,
for example,
or ISO,
but always from the same container image.
Yeah.
Alright. I broke it. I mean, it seemed
to do quite well. It got the cloud
config
and then it was trying to dump the
azure for us.
Does
it need permission to run with sudo maybe?
If you're writing in
Oh, no. Value too large.
Maybe the space
somewhere?
Maybe too large for the file.
Just
to keep elaborating maybe on what Michael is
asking.
So if
whatever distro
you are you want to use, let's say,
Proximox, I I don't know how they build
their images.
If they don't provide a container image,
then no. You would you would need to
figure out how to create a container image
out of their images first.
Yeah.
But generally speaking, you can build a container
image from scratch, virtually from anything. So
I don't know if that explain.
Too large also.
No. So, Michael, okay. Now I get to
the point. So Keras is not running as
a container. So the OS itself
is not using a container engine to start
in the system,
but it's rather using OCI and container images
only as a
way to deliver
upgrades
or
create artifacts.
So
from Proxmox,
you get so you have yeah, yeah. So
you create a standard VM and that's it.
I mean, is no
container line engine running the container image. So
the container image
became your bootable system at that point. And
from that container image you start to build
off all the other artifacts you need. And
Aurora boot for instance lets you build the
ISOs, there are all these key images for
cloud or drives
a net booting installation tool. So you can
also use it for booting several
games or machines that are configured to boot
from the network.
Well, it also supports this way which doesn't
require network configuration.
So
it only requires that the DHCP server
support the DHCP proxy requests.
So if that's true, then you don't need
even to set up any TFTP server.
Nice.
Alright. Michael is
double high fiving, so that looks like he's
happy with that answer. So
have you seen my error before?
I'm not sure.
Happy to build it here if you want
on my side.
What they see, it's like having permission to
yeah. Elchon.
So it looks like
you cannot do
can
you do?
Maybe it's simply because ask. Can you do
sudo docker run? I'm trying to run this
as
sudo just to be sure because maybe the
operation doing on build folder does require a
little bit more permission.
Alright. But it's it's something weird or or
you'd have to run privilege it otherwise.
Yeah. Because it's
Yeah. I wonder if it would work with
pod man.
This looks better. Right? Stayed a bit longer
already.
Oh, no.
It's weird.
Alright. I'm gonna try it with Podman just
because I'm curious now.
I always use Podman, but I installed Docker
for this just because the documentation normally mentioned
it. I'm
curious.
I feel like I should tidy up that
builder entry.
And if it
it can't type.
If it doesn't work, it's fine. We can
always pop over to your machine and take
a look at that. But
I am definitely curious now.
But we grabbed that code in it.
We were on the building page.
So
where
is that Aurora bit stuff? Oh, yeah. No.
That we found in the Aurora bit.
Oh, yeah. No. Where where was it?
You
took one from a different place, I think.
I don't remember. I did. You're right. I
did.
Building custom cloud images. Okay. So Oh, yeah.
Oh, so you can even build the base
image by starting with a vanilla distro. Alright.
That's nice. Yeah. Yeah. But I'm definitely gonna
be hacking together some sort of Kairos arch
hybrid now.
Yeah. I think once you're really into the
hang of Keras, this is probably the way
you're going to be building most of your
images. Yeah.
Okay. So we're actually got some information here
on state sizing. This feels relevant to the
error message we're getting, potentially.
Did we put actually the
state We we didn't include no. We didn't
include that state size.
Because normally we we don't, I think.
Oh, and there was a cloud on it
right here too. So
Oh, yeah.
I got the same with pod man. Do
you wanna will I pop your screen up
and we'll take a look at a working
one? Sure.
Alright.
But I had prepared
is actually the other
type of
SSH
model. So you're gonna show us an upgrade
to the existing one? Yeah. So
if I go here,
I have an image here
based on one of the Keras existing images.
And then I'm going to install, in this
case, Ruby.
And then I can say docker build
tag.
And we can call this d t l
dot s h
row code.
And then we put 24
on it and
dot.
Now we push it.
Oh, I don't know how long this will
take.
Didn't think of that, but hopefully not so
much because I was playing with it.
Oh, yeah. You can see that I was
playing with it. So a lot of the
layers were already there. TTL.sh
is such a great service. Yeah. I don't
even know who's responsible for it, but I
use that, like, every workshop or conference I
go to. It's just so handy.
Yeah. It's so good. I I don't know
how they offer it, but I'm happy that
they do.
Okay. So now we have this image here.
Right? And I can just jump into
our machine that we already had
here. If you remember, it was running
this Kubernetes
instance.
And here, we have the Keras agent,
and you can say upgrade
source OCI
and then paste
the image that you want to
upgrade to.
Well, that's running. I'm I'm curious about the
immutability aspect there. So how how
does this work? Is it just a immutable
file system? Have you just toggle it? Is
it don't accept right? It's like
is there what's going on here?
Basically,
have this
I think the best place to go would
be I think in the computation, we have
some some image about
how
this process goes.
A B,
what is it upgrade?
But maybe you can explain in the meantime,
it's alright that way. Yeah.
Basically,
there are
so it works differently based on the
if the system is using configured for trusted
boot or not. So
on trusted boot,
you have
the whole system as FEI files,
and that means you're going to have
an active and passive and the recovery
FEI file in the system, those are actually
handled in this moment. If you are not
using TrustedBoot instead,
those will be images that are mounted
read only in the system.
And they are
images that are created
the fly,
so the container image is pulled and
the image file is being created from the
container image in the system. And then
there is an internal component that we call
IMUCORE
in Kairos,
which does the mounting during the boot sequence.
And for instance, when it's running in Trusted
Boot, actually ImmuCore runs as a unit system
from the early stages and then hands over
to System B when hands into user mode.
And yeah, this is basically in a nutshell
what Maury is
showing you what's going to happen. Yeah, here
you have the active, passive and transition image.
Basically, we're putting everything,
like like moving things around. Right? Your active
becomes the passive. Then what we're building is
the transition image. And then once this finishes,
it goes into active. That means that if
for some reason
this process failed,
you can always go back to the previous
one that was working.
And then we can reboot again.
On top of that, there are also boot
assessment strategies,
which
basically detects if the active system is not
working properly and it will select the password.
So if the upgrade here
would have
succeeded but the image is bad, so it
doesn't boot correctly,
the system would basically detect that.
Nice.
So what we should see here when you
log in is that you have the Ruby
tool. Correct. Yep.
And then, like I was saying, once once
you get more
into
you probably
sorry. Ruby dash v, I think it is.
Yeah. We can see that we have Ruby
installed. Well, once you get more into Kairos,
this might be a bit not
the way you want to handle your images
because
we have a way to keeping track
of the OS.
Cairo
wait.
So we we have a way of keeping
track of the image that you
are spinning into.
And you might want to have your own
versioning here. Right? Your own cadence.
Like, we we release our images
when we have, I don't know, new features
of our patches. But maybe you have a
higher security
level. Right? Like, maybe you're patching things much
faster than someone else or than us in
this case. So
you you also can go into the
we saw this with the
building
from scratch guide
where you're going to be passing
the version
oh, yay. Where where did I go?
I get lost a bit.
Yeah. When you pass the version, this will
be the version of your system that you
will see here. So then you can keep
your own cadence of images.
Yeah. And that's what it takes, basically. What
you're seeing now,
Marius yeah. Marius showing you is that
in in just those few lines, you pull
the Ubuntu image as a base,
and you use the Keras init tool, which
converts that image into a Keras based image,
which what
I was previously mentioning, it means it's going
to start some base packages that are needed.
For instance, if it was Alpine, it would
start
things that are necessary for booting properly.
For instance, if it's trusted boot, it would
need
systemd component. If it's not trusted boot, it
will need grab. So it would Yeah. Pull
grab in, these kind of things.
Cool.
Very interesting.
That was this one here. So basically, here
we went through the whole process of
maintaining the images. But, yeah,
at some point, you obviously want to have
a better way to keep in track because
you probably want to put this on your
pipeline. Right? You don't wanna be doing those
manually,
which is exactly what what we're
doing, putting it on the on the pipeline.
And for that, we have the if you
see the repository,
our image is as simple.
Our Dockerfile is this, and that's it.
This produces all the different
Ubuntu OpenSUSE
with or without k three s or k
zero s.
All the different versions are done just with
this simple
structure
because at the end of the day,
you can base from anything
you tell it to start. Right?
Cool. Yeah.
Alright. Let's talk about
the the project itself then. Right? I will
pop us back over here.
I think what we've shown people
is that building
your own Linux distribution
for loading and Kubernetes isn't that hard. We've
never had a chance. The fact that this
is all based on the
OCI artifact and container fail.
It's easy for anyone to come along and
start customizing that, which has been hard for
many years. Right? Nobody ever really enjoyed building
virtual machine MQ. I
had a quick look on GAP. I see
this is a a gold project open source.
It's a CNCF sandbox.
You know People wanted to contribute and start
having some fun with Kairos. What is the
best way for them to get involved and
help shape the future of the project?
Yeah. I think there are many areas in
where Kairos
opportunities
where you can get involved in the project.
There is for for example, if there's a
distro that we're not tackling,
you could bring that in
documentation,
of course.
I I think
the
interesting part that we didn't get to talk
about is that one way of installing things
in Keras is bringing in bundles.
So let's say you wanna have Calico already
pre installed
in your Kubernetes
stack. You can just say
bundle and put Calico.
All of that right now we have it
as a community
support.
And so it really depends on
the community to come and suggest
and and ideally
open up PR with the project that they
want to see there.
And and and that way, we can grow
the different options that people can get almost
from the ground when when they
spin up a new
Kairos machine.
So, yeah, there are many different areas. We
we
we have, for example, office hours. You can
show up and just make questions or suggestions
or
yeah. Like, just like we're having right now
this conversation,
we're than happy to to have it with
you.
And
We're we're open source. You there are many
ways in in which you can
come and contribute.
Alright. The bundle concept is interesting.
So
assuming I want to build an image that
has,
you know,
journal d log forward and baked into it,
then I can configure an OCI layer that
just does that. If I want to install
Cilium, I'm assuming I can have something that
does that. If I want to make maybe
I want it to have
tail scale on it and I want it
to join my tail net, I'm assuming there
could be a layer for that.
How do the bundles work then? Do you
have to have guarantees that they all come
from the same base,
or does it not really matter? I I'm
curious about how that works.
Bundles are basically,
again, distributed also CI images.
Anybody can actually create bundles. So it doesn't
really
restrict in any way on how you can
also distribute bundles.
Right? So
the bundles are a mechanism in Keras to
have
additional way to supply configuration for the system
or
ways how the system should
change the way how it works because it
can also extend the cloud config mechanism. So
with a bundle, you can feed cloud config
during installation, for instance,
and doing other things. So bundles is the
way
to run configuration,
you can do that by distributing the bundle
as OCI image, but also just as a
simple tarballs
if you want to. So there is really
no restriction.
And we have a community bundles repository where
community
can contribute new bundles,
but also providers. So for instance, we have
the kubeadmin
provider,
which enables
Keras to to use QB admin or microcades,
for instance, well. So there are other Kubernetes
distribution. This this is all
all kind of
feature requests or even, you know, contribution that
we are welcome to to have. So even
get to know how where you would be
interested to see more support in terms of
also of Kubernetes support, but not only.
Yeah. Maybe one thing that
I guess is the first one I'm I'm
doing in an open source project is
because normally you invite end users. Right? Like,
come bring bring your suggestions or your or
or the features that you want to see
in the project. But in our case, being
a
CNCF project,
I would also invite other CNCF projects to
join us because
recently we had the experience that people
from K0S
said like, Hey, wait, why isn't K0s
having
the same level of
integration as K3s, for example? And they came
and started putting
PRs and we worked together, and now
the system improved
thanks to that. And I I think there
are so many projects out there if you
see the landscape, right, like the typical joke
in every presentation about the size of the
landscape.
But it's true. I mean, is there is
so much it is so hard to take
the time to understand them and integrate them
properly in a project.
So if
the people from those projects come and work
together with us in this case, then Kairos
can give the best experience for the Kairos
users
to to
get a glimpse on their projects as well.
Awesome. Thank you.
I was also
scanning your bundle docs there as well. And
that's a really cool approach to doing this.
It did raise one question, and I don't
want us to go on much longer, but
it'll also end up just sat here with
the last loads and loads and and loads
more questions.
Some of these bundle ideas and, again, I'm
looking at the community bundles repository as well.
Right? Some of these things
probably need configured or need access to some
sort of secret material.
Is there a best path forward for working
this? What is the you know, typically with,
like, deploying a virtual machine or a container,
some sort of handoff. Right? You see, now
you're a workload within this workload identity pool.
You could speak to a secret manager in
the cloud and and do stuff that way.
I'm assuming that would probably still work. But
what about the edge scenarios or the bare
metal scenarios?
How like, is this a path that's been
solved, a problem that's been solved yet or
not?
I know that's a big question, but I
hope I kinda got that across.
It makes a lot of sense.
I would say
you have a limit, right? Like if
you're talking about the edge, you could air
gap everything,
put it there,
and and
you would have, like, this small
network that the system would have access to.
Of course,
you would have limitations there on how
if there's a password there somehow ends up
in the hands of someone,
you can't you can't do much at that
point. What we're working on, and there is
some functionality already in Keras, is that you
can do remote attestation. So if there is
connection to server,
you could potentially
tell the system to not boot if you're
using the trusted boot mechanism.
But if if you're not at that high
degree of security,
I would say, it's very hard because at
the end of the day, it's a Linux
box. Right? Yeah.
So I'm assuming if I wanted to do
an Kubernetes
cluster with KTS running on Keras images, I'm
just stuffing that joint token into the cloud
config. Is that is that the answer?
Yep. Yeah. Got it. And there's nothing wrong
with that. Right? You just you've gotta understand
your security posture to make that safe to
do so. I mean, this is how the
cluster API project works as well. That's just
so yeah. And people won't be won't be
too disfamiliar with that. What what we've seen
for example in a project is people who
had
it was an edge project and they had
some sort of,
I don't know,
remote device, let's say, a phone that had
connection to the server.
And through that connection, they would allow,
to say, okay.
If you see the connection, then the system
can keep performing. If the connection is cut
or the you get connection to a different
service,
then, you you cannot continue performing. Something like
that. But you would have to come up
with, most of these solutions depending on on
the scenario.
I don't think we have something out of
the box
per se, right, Tottori?
So we don't have a mechanism to recognize
hosts that are down, but we have the
a k management service that allows you to
isolate
machines of a cluster from booting.
So you can basically build on top of
that because it's a controller.
So you can
still use that in Kubernetes and control which
machine basically
can boot or not boot in a cluster.
So you can do this kind of hardcore
configuration, I would say, if you are strict
in security terms.
And, yeah, I mean, this is this is
one of the most, I would say,
interesting area when you can when we are
looking for security features
among also with trusted boot support
that we have.
Alright. I'm gonna say I'm gonna keep saying
one last question, but, you know, I'm I'm
just I'm curious and I'm having fun. Cool.
Cool. Are you actually running
Cloud in it on a machine, or is
your KAIROS agent responsible
for handling that?
Running, sorry? Running cloud. Are
you actually running cloud in it or is
the Keras agent consuming the cloud config and
executing it? Oh, it's the Keras agent consuming
the cloud config. Yeah, it's not the real
cloud init. No, no, it's very
So we provide
Yeah, it's very good question. It's like we
provide a compatibility layer to cloud init
basically.
Yeah, that's amazing. Because that, you know, that
means that instead of stuffing secrets into my
cloud config, I mean, I could contribute something
to the Keras agent.
They could pull the cloud config remotely,
and then I can make assertions against MAC
addresses and say, okay. You are allowed to
obviously Yes. It's slightly better posture. It's not
great, but one step at a time. Right?
So I've got ideas. I
I've I've got ideas. Very good point. Yeah.
Alright.
I don't wanna take up any more of
your time. We've been at this now for
nearly an hour and a half. I would
just say, firstly, it's such a cool project.
The smile on my face throughout this has
been completely genuine. I can't wait to start
kicking the tires and having fun with this.
I would also say the documentation has been
fantastic. I don't think there's ever been a
time where I've asked a question that Mauro's
not been able to open the docs page
and say, here's the thing here. And that
is very rare for our project. So kudos
on that. Nice. And let's assume that people
watching this, they're smiling too. They wanna check
this out.
They know either CNCF sandbox project. Right? There's
a lot of them these days. They may
want some confidence that there's forward momentum with
the project. Maybe you can give us an
idea just in the last few minutes about
what is the
future and the road map for Kairos.
And yeah, anything else you can share would
be fantastic.
Yes.
Basically,
most of the focusing point would be on
streamlining the factory usage of Kairos. So what
you have just been going with the documentation,
like building images is going to be streamlined
a lot.
So, we didn't show it off today, but
we are working on a web UI that
lets you build
every combination
of
artifacts.
So, you start from a container image, you
go through this very high level
process where you get all the artifacts you
need,
including also things like, again, I keep repeating,
but trusted boot, but it's in that sense,
when we talk about trusted boot, things get
complex quickly when you have to deal with
building artifacts. So, it's something very much appreciated
when you look at that.
And with that, also, are planning to have
our own Keras operator, which provides the compatibility
layer with copy.
So currently,
we don't have our known operator in doing
that. We rely on system upgrade controller for
doing upgrades in Kubernetes.
But we are just using it as a
tool because of course
it's providing the features that we need for
doing the upgrades.
And yeah, we are
going to have our own solution on top
of that, that allows us to pilot that
also from a copy perspective
and integrate with
our factory lane. So that's very much important.
So you can start from defining your OS
to having bootstrapped
bare metal clusters
too,
with almost zero configuration.
So this is our vision going to the
process from build from scratch
the system you want, keep repeating that as
many time you want for doing automated upgrades
and consume that
from the cluster.
Nice.
Alright. Well, again, thank you so much for
your time, both of you. Any final parting
words?
Contribute. Actually,
thank you. Thank you for your time. It
was very nice.
That was a nice
Yeah.
And, I mean, I'm happy that documentation kind
of worked today.
No. I mean, jokes
aside, I mean, thank you. Thank you a
lot for your time. Yep. Much appreciated. It
was a good time. Have fun. And if
you need help with Kairos, just join our
channels. And, we're there in the CNCF,
Slack.
Just reach out.
All right. Well, thank you again for your
time. Thank you to everyone who watched. Also
the links to the channels, the GitHub, etcetera
will be in the description
very, very soon. Yeah, have a great day
and a great rest of your week and
we'll see you all next time. Thanks. You
too. Ciao. Thank you. Ciao.
The Q and A, we've learned so much
in every way.
Thanks for watching Rawkode
Academy
and Rawkode
Live today.
Kairos